but uh
um good evening and welcome to this
meeting the executive I will now read
out the emergency evacuation
announcement there are no planned fire
drills so if the alarm activates please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
via your nearest fire exit the two fire
exits through the partition doors are
currently not in use due to ongoing
Works therefore the fire exits are
through the main doors of the hall or
the store room adjacent to the stage
the fire assembly point is the
roundabout Island in front of the main
entrance to the building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off mobile
phones or turn them to silent please
toilets and hand washing facilities are
available in the foyer area
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you or
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording these are all switched
on and ready for you to speak
so you do not need to adjust them please
make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
voting will be done on a show of hands
in line with the constitutes a
constitution I will ask for a show of
hands four and then against
recommendations and we'll also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting
good
evening members and welcome to this
meeting of the executive on
Tuesday the 11th of October 2022.
if I can turn to the first item on the
agenda which is apologies for absence
I've been made aware this afternoon that
councilor Danielle Belton is absent due
to illness
everyone else is here
item two non-members attending this is a
regular standing item now councilor
Wilson but once again you're very
welcome to this meeting of the executive
thank you for giving up your time and I
don't see any other members or members
of the public in the room tonight
agenda item three minutes of the meeting
held on the 27th of September
members are the minutes agreed
agreed thank you
item four to receive any Declarations of
Interest are there any Declarations of
Interest members
none being declared thank you
item five questions on notice from
counselors uh there are none so we move
on then to item six and
um that's matters referred to the
executive and reports from other
committees there are two reports from
the overview and scrutiny committee
councilor Stuart Wilson and chairman of
the overview on scrutiny committee will
introduce both reports and I think the
first report is the one team
transformation program strategic
partnership with Brentwood Borough
Council
um just to give you the background where
this highlight report came from it was
members of the overview and scrutiny
committee
um just wanted a really a highlight
report and update so there was nothing
really driving it other than just
keeping an eye on what was going on
in discussion at our meeting and
reviewing the report we found that the
program is largely on track there are
some issues but they've been identified
and I think members of my committee were
content that they were being managed
satisfactorily
um
of particular interest to the members of
my committee were there's been some
issues with fully imposed and that's a
risk that's been accepted and from that
the the real concern was potential cost
escalation if we start to use lots of uh
tempering staff or agency staff
but we're confident that that is that's
being managed so that's an overview of
the report I don't know if Mr Hopkins
wants to add anything
Peter no it'll come
thank you I think only just decided
today it's obviously um a lot going on
behind the scenes uh he said in in terms
of the road map we are broadly where we
went to be in terms of achieving
um targets and Milestones and I think
there's a there's
um a lot of
dry topics going on in terms of I.T
alignments uh sort of policies and the
like where people are working sort of
hard in the background to sort of bring
to sort of the fruition I think we can
see the benefits of that in the next
couple of months thank you
thank you Mr Hutton thank you councilor
Wilson any questions any questions for
councilor Wilson
I was quite intrigued that um at last
week's overview on scrutiny uh the
deputy leader and I got away with it
because we weren't invited to
join Greg Campbell and be a supporting
act in his report or to the committee
although we were sitting as members of
the public that evening so we we heard
the uh heard the debate so
just in case so so there we are
um
just before we go to the recommendations
I would just like to make one or two
observations we would have to bear in
mind that in the nicer sense this isn't
just about the overview and scrutiny
report this is about the executive
looking at the report as well uh and I
would just like to make some
observations
first of all the deputy leader councilor
Cheryl Rowe and myself met Emily Ewell
this morning we had a short meeting with
her because of getting our Diaries
together but that was nice she joined a
strategic director yesterday
and
so we note that in 3.3 as well as also
the point that in Winslet will be
leaving his post the Strategic director
at the end of October due to health
issues and we're really sorry to see
that that happened but uh quite
understand the reasons
um we warmly welcome the six directors
who have set out their appointments set
out in 3.7 and we note the fact that
there's three appointments still to be
made and it would be a little naive to
think that you know everything would be
in place two minutes after we put the
structure together but this is actually
about
going into the market and appointing the
best people for demanding roles in this
Venture that we are in which is being
viewed by a lot of people
um
within local government as a creative
and Innovative initiative
um
3.14 it was requested by members of
feedback from residences to the impact
of the partnership is regularly sought
and reported upon at that point is there
and I can't let 3.19
be overlooked without acknowledging you
know this is about team building but
what a fantastic team building result
when 12 000 pounds is raised for charity
and I think it's just wonderful in terms
of achieving team building and also
making a significant contribution twelve
thousand pounds and so and further
events organized
um
4.3 interesting to note the anticipated
ongoing savings are still expected and
then there's the various uh
pre-scrutiny
recommendations there
so that's my only comments on the report
they're the sort of highlights of the
report but I think we turn straight to
the recommendations members if you're
comfortable councilor Wilson as they are
set out there
in item 11 10 point 10.1
certainly a bit strange with the
numbering shouldn't that be 11.1
I think that should be 11.1
um just for the for the record
um but if you're happy for us members to
take those on block I'll read them out
uh it is proposed that executive
resolves one to investigate if existing
staff can be upskilled to take on the
outstanding roles
and to adopt an appropriate methodology
to log and track issues that pose risks
for the council
is that agreed members
agreed thank you
right we now turn then to the second
um report from overview and scrutiny and
that is item 6.2 the health check review
of the asset delivery program again
you're on stage councilor Wilson but I
think you're going to be ably supported
by
councilor Webb over there and um Matt
hardwood white so you've got the
supporting act for you on that item
thank you chair
um just to set the scene in It's quite
unusual for someone who isn't the senior
responsible owner to get sight of these
reports and so
at the overview and scrutiny committee I
made it clear to members that they
weren't there to second-guess the
findings of the report because they
didn't actually undertake the work but
we were there really to amplify the
report
I think it's it the report is clear
by saying that um undertaken an asset
delivery program is what we should be
doing and it is that it's vision-led
um
the
I also said as a professional project
manager in my last career I've never
seen a set of circumstances where the
business requirement has changed so much
where inflation has come in so much and
and really it it's changed the whole
environment that we're operating and
again I think the report is clear about
that it's it's saying these are things
that couldn't have been foreseen this is
nothing to do with
um mismanagement or negligence is
literally the way the world is now
um so
really we we were we were just really
trying to amplify the recommendations
and the report
thank you councilor Wilson
councilor Webb do you wish to add
anything at this point Thank You chair
yes um thank you Council Wilson it's
good to attend um RNs um last week the
members have made some good points
um in terms of the report itself we did
agrees to report we commissioned it I
believe we're proactive in doing so
um I believe it is a balanced report it
points out some of the excellent work
that we've done as well as making five
key recommendations
um incident incidentally this is the
second health check that we've carried
out or the recommendations from the
first report were implemented and
they're listed in appendix C of this
report and we can certainly be confident
that we are following the correct
procedure
um just a couple of positives to draw
your attention to if I may section one
outlines that the development of the OBC
for the ADP has been progressed in
exemplary fashion we are followed we
followed correct procedure using
exemplary project management principles
I think that's worth highlighting and as
councilor Wilson has already mentioned
but I will also draw attention to it in
section three of the report I believe
it's page nine it makes very clear that
doing nothing is not an option and many
interviewees and stakeholders recognize
this the council remains in a position
where it has too much space while
occupying occupying an aging portfolio
of assets with Leisure and Community
assets that remain financially unviable
um that said there were five
recommendations in the report that we
discussed in some depth areas last week
that I have
um no issue with particularly in terms
of comments around the stakeholder
engagement that was carried out
and it was
um you know it was an interesting debate
because actually when you read through
the report it lists an enormous amount
of ways that we did actually as a
council engage with the community we
went through several different routes
but unfortunately at the time that we
were doing that we were living through a
global pandemic and actually our
messaging got lost amongst an awful lot
of other government messaging so maybe
it's not that surprising that our
residents didn't get the message as
clearly as we would have liked because
of the times that we were living through
and the other recommendation just to
highlight is in
um is the second point in terms of the
report speaks about recasting the
original OBC considering the changing
future operating environment and I do
think it's worth just um mentioning that
in terms of we are living in uh
extremely Changing Times
partly because of the covid-19 pandemic
the council staff operating in a very
different manner a more agile Manner and
that's a change that was not anticipated
at the start of this program and the
second change is the cost of building
work has gone up significantly a local
business manager suggested that raw
material in price
and obviously as has been mentioned
earlier this evening we have working
with Brentwood as well and that's
changing our working patterns
so
I do support the need to recast the
original OBC we have been
victims of some external factors which
we could not control
um
so yeah I think it's an excellent report
on our wholeheartedly recommend it
I would like to make some changes or to
recommend some changes if that's okay to
the actual
recommendations that came from ons I
have spoken with councilor Wilson about
this before the meeting we
uh we recognize that although we do need
to recast the vision we don't need to go
back we don't want to go back to the
start of the project and we felt that
better wording for recommendation three
would be that the executive ensures that
the program continues to be vision-led
and Forward Thinking regardless of
whether they were part of the original
outline business case
and actually the second recommendation
um
just to be absolutely clear so you're
wishing to leave that recommendation in
place but delete the words that all
options will be evaluated and replace
them with Forward Thinking right
because that recognizes the changes that
we are now facing
however we do not want to go back to the
start of the process again so to be
absolutely precise be evaluated come out
but be Forward Thinking
that's all options will be evaluated
will be removed and Forward Thinking
will go in
right do you have a second for that
change
and that's that's recommendation three
on page 6.2.4
I'll tell you that please
I'm sure Council of Webb will be
delighted to repeat it for you so the
third recommendation will read that the
executive ensures that the program
continues to be vision-led and forward
thinking
regardless of
as you can fully remove the final
paragraph the final part of that
sentence actually couldn't we if you're
happy with that
so we'll just read that the executive
ensures that the program continues to be
vision-led and forward thinking
that simplifies it doesn't it
and I
Council of Ward sorry I couldn't quite I
can't quite hear what is actually being
said just if I can repeat back what I
think you heard and then correct me
please are you saying that the executive
ensures that the program continues to be
Vision LED and that all opinions
regardless of whether they were part of
the original outline business case was
it opinions options no
that's being left out so what I'm saying
is that the executive ensure ensures
that the program continues to be
vision-led and Forward Thinking full
stop
that's it that's it take out
that taking out everything that starts
that all options will be evaluated
evaluated regardless of whether they
were part of the original outline
business case no no no no oh because
that's what I'm hearing no it's not
what's being said councilor Webb would
you please repeat
that the executive ensures that the
program continues to be vision-led and
forward thinking
okay
right
um and the second recommendation we need
to recognize that the risk register has
been presented to ons previously so we
could just amend that to say that a risk
register stroke issues log be presented
to the overview and scrutiny committee
on a regular basis
recognizing the fact that they have
already seen a copy of the risk register
before
so that a risk register issues will be
presented to the overview on scrutiny
committee on a regular basis so those
words added yeah
so those are the only
and a final Edition right
um and this is because it was actually I
believe it was missed out on the paper
when it was printed as an executive we
need to note the report itself
um and the wording that I would suggest
for that is that the health check review
of the asset delivery program and their
recommendations contained there in be
noted
right I'm just waiting for officers to
note those
four recommendations right
hold those recommendations in your mind
um I think Council sparing you were
happy to Second those
yes chairman thank you
right
I just want to go back on one or two
things
before I do hold white do you wish to
add anything
and nothing I think at this time
chairman
thank you very much indeed thank you to
you and your team for all the work going
on behind the scenes to commission this
work uh I know fantastic amount of work
on this and other things that your team
do
um
first of all I want to emphasize the
fact that when that report was
commissioned there was all sorts of
speculation within the wider community
that it wouldn't be published it
wouldn't be open and transparent it is
published it is open and transparent
there is no cover-ups going on here and
actually it was the overview and
scrutiny committee uh quite rightly that
had sight of it first when their report
was published a couple of weeks ago so I
want to dispel them if that there is
anything going on that isn't open and
transparent there's nothing in this
asset delivery program that is not open
and open to scrutiny
the second thing that I want to make
clear is the fact that the asset
delivery program the reasons for
carrying it out are as robust today as
they were several years ago when the
work started we cannot continue to have
Surplus buildings in this District which
are costly to maintain and where we are
wasting Council taxpayers money I accept
that there is an emotional attachment to
certain of our buildings and I accept
that we should be under scrutiny to make
sure that we make best use of taxpayers
money but at the same time we have to
remember our priorities that we publish
on every single agenda to be financially
sustainable early intervention and I
would suggest actually we failed on that
because what we're doing now we should
have done quite a few years ago in terms
of reviewing our assets to maximize our
assets
and to enable communities so when people
pick off individual buildings and they
think in their eyes that we should be
preserving them in perpetuity then I'm
afraid that cannot happen it wouldn't
happen in any Authority and we as
custodians of the 85 000 or so residents
that we represent should not be
supportive of that sort of wastage
in terms of the report itself I think
the recommendations are very balanced
and very reasonable
um I think there's lessons for us to
learn for me to learn in terms of the
way the engagement process was carried
out and the consultation process was
carried out but then
um I think it's absolutely right as
councilor Webb said to acknowledge that
we had a pandemic of the proportions
none of us have ever seen before
and I think we have to hold our hands up
and accept that on reflection with
hindsight we we could and we should have
done better and I take my part of the
responsibility for that but it wasn't
done with any malice or intent not to be
straightforward in what we were doing
it's just one of those things with the
benefit of hindsight you look at
but we did have the greatest pandemic
and threat to life
um that we our generation have ever seen
um
the other thing is that we have
circumstances have changed there was
obviously the influence of covid uh
coming out of that there is a different
way of the council now working much more
acceptance of hybrid working
there is the partnership with our
colleagues in Brentwood which has
changed some of our working practices
and will have influence moving forward
and certainly the impact on costs and
the business case which we had a matter
of only two or three years ago frankly
we might as well tear that up and put it
in the bin because it is no no longer
realistic when you look at the rates at
which building costs are going up so we
have to rethink the whole strategy and
you know there may be criticism that
this Administration has wasted some
money
but the reality is do you go on
knowingly wasting money or do you
recognize that circumstances have
changed to the extent that you need to
reflect pause and look at the whole
program again and that is what we are
responsibly doing but a lot of the money
that has been spent is
used on various reports that we've had
and it is not wasted it is actually
informing us but I think this review of
what we're doing the health check is
very very positive so that's all I
really wish to say there may be some
questions in the Light report I've said
councilor Hefty
thank you chairman uh just I agree with
you on the report that it's well
balanced but the recommendations in the
report could be a little bit more plain
English so you have to really look at
them to understand and get the meaning
and that would be good also where it
recommends that we come back and review
this in 12 months time we've actually
got quite a few important decisions to
make over the next few months or the
next six months so I like stock code
decisions and stuff like that so maybe
it might be good to come back for your
view after the stop though stop go
decisions are made
I I I think colleagues on uh overview
and scrutiny always happy to look at
these things so that um it would be an
annual review because it's looking to
say is the business requirements still
there but there's nothing to stop you
doing it before okay so maybe that can
go in and again I've got a signature on
the report doesn't say which officer
well I think the the point on review it
just needs to be built in you know the
chairman of r s is here and it needs to
be built into the work plan I don't see
the need for a formal recommendation on
that but it's noted from from this
meeting and who did the reports it's
just got a signature not
okay
Matt thanks Matt well done
right lovely
um
Council Ward
thank you very much leader I I think the
report tells a very good story
and I think that is important that we've
actually got a story that people can see
annotated out properly to explain
everything
and I think that's important and the
fact that it's come from the overview
and scrutiny committee they have worked
with it and they brought that forward I
think that adds a lot of credence to a
lot of the issues that have come up and
I think it's a real myth buster in my
opinion I'd like to thank the overview
and Review Committee for actually
looking and bringing this forward to us
thank you
a good piece of work right any other
points
nope okay well we will go to the
recommendations
um and um
officers do you wish us to read those
out again
do you want to go through one to four
now
councilman I'm happy to do that chairman
so first recommendation is that going
forward with the ADP consideration of
the impact of our carbon footprint be
given when buying in services and
procuring goods members who's that
agreed
the the second second recommendation is
that a risk register
issues log be presented to the overview
and scrutiny committee on a regular
basis members is that agreed
the third recommendation is that the
executive ensures that the program
continues to be vision-led and forward
thinking
members is that agreed
and then the fourth recommendation is
that the health check review of the
asset delivery program and their
recommendations contained there in be
noted members is that noted
thank you
right we turn then to item number seven
on the agenda tonight which is a report
from on
the cost of living
because it was being updated it was only
two weeks ago that we were sitting in
this room listening to the initial
report but it's nice we did actually say
we would have
um updates at every executive so I hand
over initially to councilor Williams to
guide us through the report
thank you chairman
the decision sorry the decision being
recommended this evening is for members
to review and note the current version
of The Joint cost of living action plan
for rochard and Brentwood has agreed it
has agreed at the executive on the 27th
of September this year
we have developed an action plan
which provides a whole system approach
to support residents businesses and
staff in responding to the cost of
living issues and to enable individual
and Collective support through a suite
of preventative and personalized
measures
it must be remembered this action plan
is a live document
evolving on a daily basis and will be
informed not only from any governmental
changes but also a number of sources
such as health
colleagues housing revenues and benefits
Department
department for work and pensions citizen
advice Bureau and voluntary community
and social Enterprises
organizations that are on the front line
providing services to Residents I'd like
to thank Tracy Lilly and her team for
putting this remote together in such a
timely manner thank you thank you
chairman thank you councilor Williams
Tracy Lilly do you wish to add any
comments to that
I'll be brief chair it's just to say
that one of the key factors and I've
mentioned this before is that this is
our response in terms of the cost of
living crisis it's not what we can do to
respond to it it's around our
coordination efforts and I'm really
pleased to say that we've already set up
the working group that will meet on the
20th of the week minutes in the 24th so
that will really drive it forward so I'm
hoping in future Executives I'll be able
to develop the dashboard that I'll bring
back rather than the action plan but we
just have to be mindful that we will be
working with voluntary sector
organizations so it may be that data is
not available on a monthly basis but
I'll develop that and bring it back to a
future executive
thank you very much indeed and
tremendous thanks to you and your team
for the work you've done in pulling this
together any questions members Council
of order thank you
um will this be going live on our
website
the website's got enough information on
it because it is it's a good landing
page and it gives people the the places
that they need to go we're actually
developing through the working group of
comms plan as well so the idea is that
we're constantly going out there to the
communities through whether it be the
video ideas that we're doing through
newspapers all of that kind of thing so
I'm conscious I don't want to bombard
people with an action plan that might
not be relevant to everybody it's about
getting the key messages out there I
think I think that's what I was aiming
at yeah thank you
any other questions
now the only um
point I would make is can we just be
aware when we're attaching an appendix
that some of the
and I'm sure it's the same for Brentwood
colleagues but some of the Brentwood
terminology for example prayed is a
little bit of a strange term for us here
in Rochford and I'm sure there's other
bits of terminology that are a bit so
can we just be aware that when we are
putting out reports that
essentially cover because it's the same
report we just are a little bit aware of
that because
and
policy resource and economic development
is that the um oh not that too bad there
um but uh you know somebody it's just
nice for us to recognize this
terminology that we don't all uh all
share okay no other questions
okay I think that appendix is really is
really good
um so if members agree we'll turn to the
decision being recommended at 1.1 and
that is for members to review and note
the current version of The Joint cost of
living action plan for Rochford and
Brentwood has agreed at the executive on
the 27th of September 2022 members is
that noted
noted thank you very much indeed that
actually concludes the uh this meeting
tonight at
2001 this evening so thank you very much
indeed for your attendance members and
officers and of course councilor Wilson
who seems to be a standing visitor to
this meeting you're always very welcome
thank you very much indeed